If you had the power to come
back from the dead, what would you do?
The government wants to capture
and experiment on you forever
and now everyone else,
including your parents,
either wants to help them or kill you
for bounty.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do and how to beat
the black ghosts in our gin.
This kid doesn't know this,
but he's about to die.
A brutal death.
Kei here is a normal kid living his
boring life when on this particular day,
something seems off in class.
They learn about ajin,
a group of supernatural beings
thought to be immortal.
This group was discovered 17 years ago
in Africa and since then have been hunted
by the government, with massive bounties
being placed on them all over the world.
However, the teacher says that
any one of them could be an ajin, as
no one knows until they die
and come back to life.
Later on, he heads home but is in his own
head just as he crosses the street.
Then, suddenly, a huge truck hits him
running over, crushing his body
and killing Kei in the process.
His lifeless corpse just lays there
in the middle of the street,
but this is only the beginning.
The crowd suddenly gathers near the crash
truck when something insane happens.
Kei wakes up, covered in his own blood.
Good as new as his body emits a mysterious
black smoke and he begins to freak out.
He's an ajin,
and now the world is coming for him.
OK? OK, let's not panic, but
we need to get our heads in the game here,
even if we could trust our friends,
which we can't.
They wouldn't be able to help us
as they are kids, after all.
And like what we learned from our teacher,
there's a massive bounty
placed on our heads,
which means we can't trust anyone.
We know our own home isn't safe anymore.
And so I would first head
to an ATM away from the crime scene
and take out as much cash as I could.
And I'll also get a new change of clothes
because I'm bloody as all hell.
The next thing that I would do
is head to a convenience store
and get some food
that will last us a few days.
Hear me out now.
It's safe to say that the first few hours
after the accident is
when we'll have the best chance
to not be spotted as the news works
to catch up with the current events,
meaning
we don't have to worry about cops yet.
And that also means that we should have
a little bit of time before
our own face is plastered
all over the news.
We're going to have to be content
with giving up our friends and family,
at least for the foreseeable future,
especially if being a is considered
to be as insane
as people make it out to be ,
and we can't go anywhere
where the cops would think to look for us.
The first thing we need to do is
to get out of this highly populated area.
Japan is a land of forests and mountains,
with some 25
million hectares covering
67% of the country.
This means that I'm going to make my way
out of town to a heavily forested
area to use as cover as I plan
my next few moves.
Kei is freaking out
and there's a bounty on ajin's, which
means he can't even trust his own friends.
He runs off quickly
before the ambulance and police arrive.
He thinks his life is over,
but actually it's just starting
and it's about to get a whole lot worse.
K runs into the forest and is terrified.
He notices flashing lights in the distance
where his house is.
The cops have already showed up
at his home, which means nowhere is safe.
He decides to call a childhood
friend, Kaito, who we see is already
packing a get out of town bag.
How convenient.
Just then, a policeman spots him
and he makes a run for it.
He can't trust anyone,
not even the law itself.
Kei rushes through the trees and bushes
until he trips and injures himself.
The police is almost on him.
Suddenly, Kaito jumps out of nowhere
and knocks the policeman out
as the two run towards Kaito's bike.
Kaito has a plan for them to head up
north to a faraway village,
but what he doesn't know
is that they'll never get there.
Meanwhile, this mysterious white haired
guy here shows up at the police set up
near K's House.
He's from the Ministry of Health
and is an ajin hunter expert.
He tells the cops how to really catch
ajin's using tranquilizer guns
as he prepares them for the deadly hunt
that will now span all over Japan.
He also sent his assistant to go, check
and see if her sister,
who is recovering in the hospital,
knows anything.
But this will cost him and his assistant
a lot more than they think
back on the run.
K and Kaito are filling up on gas
as they notice a van coming.
They quickly rush off, but it's too late.
The two men of the car
recognize Kei's face as his identity
is now all over the news.
The boys eventually stop again
as Kei needs to go to the bathroom.
But just as Kei waddles off
behind the bushes to go pee,
he's attacked by the men
following them in the van.
My oh my two young kids
not thinking things through
how original Kei and Kaito are acting
too carefree about this situation
and are acting like freaking idiots.
Kei has an end with Kaito
as he is not wanted or affiliated
with Kaito in any significant way,
at least on paper as of yet.
This means that Kaito could have gone
places without drawing attention.
This also means that Kaito
should have dropped off a few feet before
or after the gas station
and should have filled up the bike alone,
with Kei
waiting in the bushes nearby or something.
Even if there was no passing cars at that
time, Japan is a country with around
the same amount of CCTV cameras installed
as the United Kingdom with a.
Around 6 million cameras nationwide.
These kids were just asking to be caught,
and while we're at it,
if I was escorting a friend
across the country
and he was a super mutant,
I would at least start Googling
what it means to be an ajin.
This way,
we could have just let Kei die
without helping him
knowing that either
his ghost or Kei himself
would come back from the dead
to kill those guys.
And if what we read online was wrong,
then Kei died sucks to be him.
We could have gone back home anyways.
Problem solved.
The two men violently
beat up Kei, and Kaito tries to stop them.
one of them
accidentally kills Kei by choking him.
But that's
when Kei sees the most horrifying thing.
A black ghost as his mind wanders
outside of his body for a second
as he finally wakes up,
and this time pissed off commits a loud,
piercing scream that paralyzes everyone,
including Kaito for a second.
Kei yells at Kaito to get moving,
giving Kaito
the shock that he needed to shake it off,
giving the boys enough time to escape.
As Kei tries to figure out what the hell
that terrifying Black Ghost was
back in the van,
the two men catch up again near Kei
just as they are stopped and paralyzed
on the train tracks by something.
And that's when one of them looks up
and sees a dark, black, sinister figure.
Echoing Kei's words
from its faceless mouth, the man screams
in horror as the train kills them,
but these two boys can't catch a break
as they moments later pass
a man on a motorbike who spots Kei's face.
And that's when the chase is on. Hold
on, hold on.
Seriously, you're a wanted fugitive,
and you couldn't even afford
to wear a scarf over your face or a mask.
The whole country is looking for you.
Like, What are you doing?
Kei should have been a greedy bastard
like us and swapped for the better,
more face covering helmets with Kaito.
This was an easy fix.
Motorbike man forces them off the road
as Kei
and Kaito crash, seemingly
killing Kaito and badly injuring Kei.
Motorbike Man comes
near Kei and is about to kill him.
Kaito then gets up.
He's alive and pissed as all hell
and beats the shit out of motorbike guy
with a rock.
Unfortunately for Kei,
he can't move due to his leg being broken,
and good as new.
The two boys then stop over at Kaito's
safe house to fill up on equipment
for the long journey ahead.
Kei and Kaito then discuss plans
for the next step of this escape plan
as Kei wants to just live in peace.
So Kaito suggests that his village again
is a possible option as he claims
it's a place where no one would care
if he was an ajin.
Kaito then lets Kei rest as he goes off
to the nearby store to get some supplies.
Kei knows what Kaito doesn't,
that this journey is too dangerous
for a human
and one that will cost a lot of lives.
Elsewhere, the assistance of white haired
man shows up at the hospital to see if
her sister knows more about Kei and ajin's
than what she already told the cops.
And this is when Kei sister mentions
the scariest thing ever.
She claims that when she and Kei
were kids, their pets suddenly died.
And that's when Kei mentioned
that there was this faceless black ghost
hovering over their bodies,
but she personally couldn't
see anything there herself.
This stuns the assistant, and her face
gives off more than she realizes.
But just then, her body contorts
violently up in the air as she gets
stabbed by something,
and then her chest bursts open with blood.
It's a black ghost,
and only she can see it.
Kei's sister screams in horror
as the assistance lifeless corpse thumps
back down to the floor.
The invisible monster
then ends up killing and ripping
everyone apart in the room, as the sister
can only watch in terrifying fear.
She can't see what we can see that there's
an insanely huge and blood curdling
monster in the room with her, and that's
when the assistant comes back to life.
Turns out she's an ajin
who shit's about to go down,
but the only thing we have on our side
is the fact that other people
are in this shit show with us.
My thinking is to fight fire with fire
and set this one out
until everything goes to shit.
So what if we brought
some more people into this room
to add as a further distraction?
Hospitals
usually have a button or a switch nearby
on the patients beds to alert the nurses
when patients are in need of something.
So I would have press that button
and told them
that I was in need of assistance
and dashed out of that window and waited
and watched as more unsuspecting nurses
would have come in.
This would no doubt cause a bloodbath
to occur, resulting in many deaths.
Then, as this shit
show went down, I would have either waited
until whatever was going on was over or
I would have worked on finding a way down
or at least away from this main room.
Because let's be honest,
what else could we have done aside
from stirring up more shit
and we love stirring up shit?
The assistant fights
this black ghost with her very own,
and they fight each other to the death,
tearing each other's limbs apart
and knocking each other around
until the assistance
black ghost kills the other one, striking
it with blunt force trauma to the head.
And we see the fall in black ghosts being
controlled by Mr Douchebag right outside.
But this all turns out
to be just a distraction, as now
sister has been taken by the infamous
surgeon called Sato or the man in the hat
secured in an unknown location.
Later, Sato asks K sister all about K
and she spells everything there is to.
Know about her brother
until Sato knocks her out.
Then back at the safe house,
Kei forms his own game plan,
using what he already knows
about Japan's statistics.
According to the Ministry of Labor,
if over 1 million people in Japan die
every year.
That means two people die every minute,
which means some of them must be ajin.
K leaves the safe house
as Kaito to remain sleeping, unaware
he doesn't have much time
until he is discovered,
so he needs to act fast, deciding that
he'll find the rest of the agenda
and hiding through the internet.
He sets off, OK, I'm just going to comment
on how unbelievably stupid this is.
You have a friend willing to help you.
Yet you're too high and mighty and noble
to let him in on your adventure.
You're a kid
with no money, food or supplies.
Kaito has a safe house, a village
and even a bike.
Remember,
he even packed a duffle bag from earlier.
He's way more prepared than Kei is.
This is why I wouldn't ditch him at all.
In fact, his plan sounds solid enough.
Aside from the fact that they may
be rushing to Keitel's village at a time
when roadblocks and alerts for Kei's
whereabouts will be at their highest,
and Kaito hasn't even been discovered yet,
so we could still use him
to continuously supply us
with food and water when we run out
as we wait for the heat to die down on us.
But even then, I would consider avoiding
heading to Keitel's village entirely.
The government, in reality,
is more than equipped to find us.
I instead would work on
finding some other way to find more
hidden agenda throughout the country,
as they are obviously better than we are
at hiding themselves, such as by searching
the online forums through a VPN.
Like the sponsor of today's video.
I'm kidding.
Calm down,
but I would consider going through
the dark web through an Onion browser
to discover other regions out there.
An Onion browser is simply a worldwide
network of servers that will pass our data
through different servers,
giving us better
levels of internet, privacy and freedom.
Now that we are one of them, finding other
ajins should be our main objectives
before anything else.
Kei then gets a phone call
from his sister's phone number,
but the person on the other line
is the man in the hat
who says he has his sister, and that if he
wants to find out why they have her phone,
he needs to come and meet him now.
Kei then dashes off as he takes
Kaito's bike, driving it for hours
until it finally runs out of gas.
But he doesn't let this stop him
as he continues the journey on foot.
Hours later, K walks
tired and dehydrated as he wonders
if he'll die from dehydration, and that's
when he finally reaches the meta point.
This meeting is going to cost him
his life more times than he will ever
want to know here, says the famous ajin
Sato and his second minion in command, Mr.
Douchebag, who Sato helped to break out
of a government lab earlier.
Sato was a man
that you don't want to mess with,
and he wants Kei to join him
and his group, who he claims
are trying to live a peaceful life.
Kei wants to know their secret and how
they get by his people with normal lives.
And lucky for Kei, Sato mentions
that his sister is also safe
and back at the hospital,
but something is not right as he senses
something is nearby.
We finally found some ajins,
which is good, but we can't trust them
just yet.
Especially after what they did
to our sister.
Desperate times, I'm sure.
But why would they kidnap
someone close to us
just to get our attention
into meeting them
unless they directly
want something from us?
And this right here is a red flag.
other than to keep an eye on them
and to not trust them fully just yet.
Even if they're technically rescuing
us, let's stay sharp.
All of a sudden,
a blow dart zips past them.
It's the police and all three ajins
take cover.
However, K is shot in the chest
and then quickly passes out.
But then, as K sleeping
body lays there, Sato and Mr.
Douche Bag smile.
There weren't any cops nearby,
and it turns out that it was Mr.
Douchebags Black Ghost who shot.
The only way to learn
how savage humans really are
is by going through
the most horrifying experience
that Kei will ever know,
and this is Sato's plan .
K wakes up
bound to a table, and his entire body
is covered in bandages and restraints.
This is truly horrifying.
Kei can barely make out the sharp
tools and knives circling around the room.
Kei notices that this is an operating
theater, and he's the star of the show.
These surgeons are definitely not board
certified as Kei
screams in horror
as he dies over and over and over again
from blood loss, organ failure, shock
and more as he continues
to relive the very worst day of his life
hating every last human around him.
And this was all part of Sato's plan.
ten days later, Sato and Mr.
Douchebag
show up like knights and fricking armor,
busting in and running around
like he had a part in The Matrix trilogy,
grooving past all the guards and security
that this lab throws at him.
The guards don't realize that all of them
are about to die, as Sato is unstoppable.
After the horrifying bloodbath
and piles of bodies right outside,
Sato pops into Kei's room and frees him
lying to his face about how he found them,
and they set off to escape.
But what Sato doesn't realize
is that this kid will.
Cost him everything that he has planned.
Soon enough, on the way out,
they come across a few terrified surgeons
as Sato tries to kill them,
but is stopped by Kei
as he accidentally kills
Sato in the process.
OK, we just screwed up in a big way.
From the way Sato killed that doctor
for no reason makes me pretty darn
sure that he'll be very happy to kill me
if I don't comply with his orders.
to grab his assault rifle
and kill him repeatedly
every few seconds
while ordering the doctors
next to me to grab any scalpels or
equipment that they have to use on Sato.
We may not know how to kill him,
but we sure as hell can slow down
his healing process
by ordering the doctors
to cut off his hands and legs completely.
And if they refuse, I'll do it myself
and then we're going to make a run for it.
And I think this is doable
because they just saw what happened.
They know we're immortal
and we have a gun.
They shouldn't have just sat there
like an idiot.
And he especially should have run away
from the exit door
as Sato was regenerating.
He just made things a lot more difficult.
Oh, I'm so annoyed, Sato regenerated
and now wholly pissed off.
He sets off through the room
looking for K and the rest of the surgeons
as he plans to kill everybody
and now considers Kei a failure,
Sato says, since ajins can't die.
He's got other plans for K.
If you chop off Annajin's head,
will the head that grows back in its place
be the same person?
Or will Kei's consciousness
remain in the chopped off head?
This is what Sato plans to find out,
and this terrifies Kei,
who is running out of time.
one of the doctors with him
is not an asshole
and says that he can show Kei the way
out of the building if he helps them.
And that's what K tries to do.
He tries to outsmart Sato
with a crude plan, but Sato is too dang
old and smart, and he beats up Kei,
but also accidentally lets the two doctors
escape.
K is about to die as Sato towers over him,
but that's when suddenly Kei's Black
Ghost comes out to defend Kei
and kill Sato, letting Kei Burley escape
with his precious young life.
And oh, goody for him.
And thanks to that nice
young doctor from earlier.
Kei follows the lines drawn on the walls
for him to follow,
leading him onto the roof.
However, as they make it near
the edge of the building,
the doctor is shot by Sato, and this looks
like the end as Sato corners them.
But Kei is able to bring out his black
ghost once again to defend himself.
This stuns Sato,
as ajin
shouldn't be able to bring out their black
ghost more than one or two times per day.
And that's
when Seattle lets out his terrifying
black ghost, and these two monsters battle
it out to the death, throwing floating
jabs and stinging slashes at one another.
The two black ghosts duke it out,
as this gives Kei enough time
to throw the injured doctor off the roof
toward safety
and Kei jumps down into the passing river.
This doctor is a sweetheart,
so let's use him as a distraction
and get away from Sato.
Kei did mostly everything right, except
for a few things now I couldn't tell you.
High up, exactly.
We are on the building,
but I'm pretty darn sure
we're at least higher than four storeys,
which would be 48 feet.
This height is the medium lethal distance.
According to the book Trauma
Anesthesia, that gives us
at least a 50% chance of death
from falling from such a height.
And if anything, I think we're around
seven storeys or higher,
which gives us a 90% chance of death.
This means that I would have used
these odds to distract Sato with my angel
healed in seconds before jumping into
the river nearby from a much safer height.
Watching cars escape unfold on
the security cameras, white haired
guy gets a call from his boss
and says that his job is now at stake, and
unless he wants to lose it, he better stop
letting engines escape left and right.
White haired guy also finds out
that the world is conducting
inhumane experiments
on Ajin's for medical purposes,
and that our genes have many uses
for society, from making drugs
to body armor, weaponry and much more.
This makes white haired guy furious,
and he decides to take matters
into his own hands and kidnaps
the Big Sartaj, an expert at gunpoint.
Meanwhile, Sato and Mr.
Douchebag go to the front of the lab,
which is surrounded by news cameras,
and tells the reporters that he's planning
a government protest rally in a few days
for against a peaceful protest.
He also releases a secret video
to the whole world,
showing that the government
inhumanely tortures against.
This shocks the world,
and everyone falls for what Sato says.
Not knowing that believing him will result
in many innocent deaths soon enough.
A few days later,
the protest takes place at the ministry.
However, not many people are there,
including Sato, although his black ghost
is there,
and so are a bunch of other scary looking
black ghosts invisible to the public.
Dear Sato's Ghost then tells them
the location of the real ajin meeting
at the real meeting of the ajins
in Japan have gathered falling for Sato's
master plan to come out of hiding to hear
what plans he has for their kind,
and that was their biggest mistake.
Hold on.
Has anyone else thought
that maybe this guy is a complete nut job?
No one knows that we are ajins,
which means we could have held the meeting
at least somewhere
oh I don't know more private, even if our.
Is wanted by the police,
it's a little weird
that Sato felt the need to hold a meeting
in an abandoned warehouse,
going to an unknown place
away from any sort of public
eye is always a risky situation,
and the fact that Sato invited us here
means that he is holding all the cards.
And in theory, if something goes wrong,
then what's to stop Sato from kidnaping us
right here?
No one's around here to help us.
Who knows what this dirty old man
will do to us if we don't like his plans?
He's an ajin, after all, which means
we can't trust anyone around here.
We see, except ourselves.
Elsewhere, White-Haired
Man sits with the kidnaped ajin researcher
and interrogates him, asking him
everything there is to know about a gents.
We find out
this is personal for him as he wants
to know how to use their abilities
for his own gain.
Hoping his wife
somehow wake up from her coma.
Here we learn all the various things
that makes a gens unique
how each black ghost is different
from the other.
How rain makes it harder for ajins
to control their black ghosts.
And that they have no cerebral limit
and that ajins communicate to black
ghosts via special electromagnetic waves
that they give off.
White haired guy listens
to every last word that this guy says
as he prepares for the wrath and hailstorm
that Santa will bring upon Japan very soon
as every day they waste is another day
that the ajins
have to mobilize their armies
as they prepare to eventually kill
every single human in the world.
Later on, Kei washes up on some random
shore far away from Tokyo.
But then on his way into the forest,
he bumps into an old lady
not wanting to seem suspicious
by running away.
He helps the old lady
back to her house and plays it cool.
Oh, OK, this old
grandma is suspicious and a problem,
but Kei did good
by not raising any suspicions.
What we should do next is to head back
to her house and lead the old lady down
on her chair or bed for a nap, and gently
and tenderly choke her to death,
violence and cruelty to the old people.
Yes, I know. But hey,
this will allow us to use our house
as a means of a temporary shelter.
We have no idea of where we are as of yet.
So now what question her on everything
there is to know about this
area and its people and maybe her ATM
details before killing her?
Now, the good thing is that
Kei should have realized
when he was being tortured
that ajin can regenerate their own
vitamins and minerals coming back to life.
Good as new post-death.
He's going to use the citizens
to make them hate the government,
and that by using that very same hate
as a means of traction to commit
terrorist attacks all over the world,
starting with one pharmaceutical company
in central Tokyo that he plans to blow up,
this company is known
for conducting experiments on ajin.
He even records and declares to the world
that he will destroy
the pharmaceutical company in a few days
and that this is only the start
of his reign of terror. OK,
this is insane.
We need to get out of here.
And not only is this old man nuts,
he is out on a quest for vengeance
that will do nothing but stir up
more shit.
The problem that I have with this plan
is that any time one group decides
to take matters into their own
hands, the responsibility
of making a good impression towards others
will rely mainly on that group's ability
of showing themselves in a positive light.
Deciding to massacre groups of people
throughout Japan will do nothing
but rally the humans against us,
even more so, so bad plan
and that is giving what the government
wants.
Making ajin seem
even more deadly than they are.
I'm willing to bet there's
a lot of undiscovered engines out there,
but I know that there are way
more humans out there than ajin.
And if they all want us to die,
then we will be beyond outnumbered,
which is why we need to leave now.
Not everyone at the meeting
is as evil as Sato, claiming that doing
this will make the world Hedajins instead.
But Sato is too much of a tyrant
to listen and orders Mr.
Douchebag
to put the disagreeing ajins to bed.
However, this red haired
dude escapes before he gets captured
and takes the first train out of Crazy
Town.
Back at this old lady's house,
Kei nervously checks out the place,
knowing that
he cannot let her find out who he is
and that at any moment
the government could show up to kill him.
He can't afford to relax,
but turns out that this old lady reveals
to Kei that she knows who he is
because she saw him on the news, but
that Kei reminds her of her own grandson.
So lucky for him, he can stay at her house
for as long as he wants.
Later on, red haired kid
reaches back to his apartment,
all covered in his own blood from earlier.
But this lady thinks he's already dead
as she tries to call him an ambulance.
And to top it off,
the government already knows who he is,
thanks to his picture being identified
at the protest rally earlier.
This kid's in trouble.
Red haired kid makes a dash for it,
knowing that if he is caught,
he will never see the light of day again
and will forever
be tortured to death over and over again.
He then jumps forwards and lands badly,
injuring himself just as he crosses
paths with white haired guy
and his assistant.
White haired guy then runs him over
about to capture him until the ambulance
arrives, picking up and in fact,
rescuing red haired kid
from the government's clutches.
He later sneakily escapes
from the ambulance by playing dead.
Well, Miami.
This kid could not have been luckier,
and it's a good thing
that that helpful neighbor of his
was shocked and.
After call the ambulance, but I suspect
we could have done this a little better.
Red haired kid chose the wrong day to wear
yellow pants, that's for sure, moron.
But honestly,
he did the best that he could have done
without taking off his shirt.
It's highly unusual
to go shirtless in Japan
unless you're at the pool or beach,
and this ain't no American college campus.
So really red haired
kid would have dragged
more attention coming back
without wearing anything at all,
but he didn't have to delay the inevitable
of dying
a slow death at the very end of his chase.
It's clear that the people after him
were no average gangsters
and that the government has now
caught on to our real ajin identity,
so I would have wasted no time thinking
we could have talked this out.
I do want to note that red haired
kid is on the seventh floor.
Red haired
kid could have simply jumped down
This gives you a great way
to get to the ground level real fast.
And two he would not have been injured
when White-Haired Man found him
and could have ran away
in full control of the situation,
and his peaceful environment works on
finding out everything there is to know
about his powers, conducting his very own
experiments on his agenda and seeing just
what the hell he can truly do.
And that's
when you hear some ruffling in the bushes.
Red haired kid pops out from hiding as Kei
kills him first before realizing
that he's another friendly ajin.
However, Kei
doesn't trust him and poisons him before
beating the Ajin out of him
and capturing him.
No one can know where Kei is.
This was incredibly smart
and well done on Kei's part.
Bravo.
Even if this kid has good intentions,
we don't know if he's being followed.
And chances are
anyone who traveled this far out of Tokyo
is going to be in some sort of trouble.
This is the very same kind of trouble
that we want to avoid.
What I would do next is to tie him up
and hide him and keep my head low
for the next few days for good measure.
If anyone did follow him, then it's either
the government pairs of dangerous thugs
or other ajins. I don't know or care.
I just don't want to be found.
Kei explains to trap, red haired guy
that he's living in peace right now
and has no interest in stopping Sato
or fighting anyone.
This angers red haired kid as he knows
what's at stake if Kei doesn't
listen to him that the city of Tokyo
will be the first to fall
with thousands dead if no one stops Sato
from destroying Japan.
Meanwhile, Sato is already well underway,
planning his greatest terrorist attack
yet, getting supplies
and help from all the other ajins
who plan to reign terror
on the country of Japan within a few days.
Sato's crew then dresses up as regular
old workers heads to the headquarters
of the pharmaceutical company,
slipping past security and planting bombs
all around inside,
setting up the most terrifying
terrorist attack in the history of Japan.
The day of the bombing comes
and the government is on high alert
and has even placed extra security
around the pharmaceutical building,
and they've even implemented
special measures thanks to what
white haired dude
found out from the ajin expert
as they release a surrounding
wall of water droplets from numerous pipes
all around the building.
But it's already too late,
and now thousands will die.
Sato arrives,
killing guards and receptionists
as he heads to the top of the building
just in time for the Grand Show.
But Sato isn't
at the pharmaceutical building.
Turns out he's at the building next door.
An eruption
then goes off and a massive, terrifying
explosion swallows the entire building
hall and Sato rides the collapsing
building down as it crashes
on top of the pharmaceutical building.
As everyone in both buildings,
thousands of innocent people
die in a matter of seconds.
It's a bloodbath, and smoke covers
the entire area as Sato wakes up
and with a special shotgun package
preparing to take on what's to come.
An elite unit from the Metropolitan
Special Assault Team.
Sato live streaming,
this battle prepares to show the world
who is better,
the best of the best of humans or an ajin
, and this is one battle
that neither of them can afford to lose.
Gunshots
go off as Sato was killed on site,
and the assault team
begins to prepare to carry him out
on a stretcher, continuously shooting him
every three seconds
to prevent him from coming back to life.
But this was all part of Sato's plan.
OK, now, while these dudes
seemingly have control of this ajin down
pat, their coordination
and timing is impeccable.
Baby claps for them.
I, however, can't help but wonder as to
why they didn't think to try other methods
other than the simplest wants to keep him
down.
It's not that regions begin to regenerate
at their exact time of death
and what Japan's finest decided to do.
While simplistic seemed
almost too tedious and risky,
I would have suggested maiming Sato
without killing him, such as conducting
a very small neurosurgical operation
on the spot by severing the connection
in the brain's prefrontal cortex
or some other , more extreme yet precise
method to make Sato's brain dead
or unable to function without killing him,
like being injured time and time again
and again doesn't regenerate
until they are dead,
which means
if we are able to prevent them from dying,
what's keeping them incapacitated?
It's safe to say that
this method would be more viable and long
lasting than simply shooting him
every three seconds
as they carry him out on a stretcher.
Because the moment he dies,
we're on the clock before he comes back
from the dead to try and kill us,
and that's a risk I don't want to take.
Suddenly, the assault?
He begins to get shot from a distance
as the best of the best,
get killed on the spot by a sniper.
Turns out that Sato
arranged for two of his ajin henchmen
to cover him from the rooftops.
The assault team panics as they tried
their very best to prevent Sato
from waking up as they tried to continue
to move him towards a special vehicle
parked in the distance
as they have their very own sniper team
who try and take out
the two ajins snipers.
But that's when these two crafty ajins
call in Mr.
Douchebag as he, using his black
ghost, terrifyingly kills
all the rooftop snipers to lose
focus as Sato finally breaks free.
And that's when all hell breaks loose.
Sato wakes up and uses his shotgun
to kill every single soldier around.
Blood spills everywhere,
as no one can seem to stop this again.
He finally finishes, killing
the last person before he calmly walks
away, showing the government and the world
just how terrifying he truly is.
Meanwhile, as he helps out,
Grandma notices
that none of the other villagers are out
and about, and his senses tells him
that something terrifying is coming,
and that's when he suddenly gets shot.
It's the police as the finest of Japan's
law force surrounds him,
forcing him to bed fake grandma farewell
and takes off into the forest,
tricking the cops
darts in the opposite direction, going
to where red haired dude still is trapped
and releases him.
Times have changed,
and K is now ready to stop Sato for good.
Teaming up with red haired dude,
the two boys then head off
but crossed paths with more Japanese
police and even white haired dude himself.
K is shot by a blow dart
and is about to pass out,
but that's when he summons
the terrifying Black Ghost , which acts
independently as K passes out
shocking, white haired dude
as his ajin assistant takes out her own
black ghost as the two ghosts battle
it out as this happens.
K and red haired dude wake up
and they make a break for Kei's Black
Ghost gets destroyed, but amazingly,
he just makes another one
as he continues to make more black ghosts.
He stunned white haired dude.
The two boys then escape to take on Sato
elsewhere across the country.
We see Sato in a recording room,
telling the world
that this was only the beginning
and that the final wave of ajin's
will come soon
to finally take over the entire country.
And if you don't want an old aged man
to take over your country,
like subscribe, comment,
tell us what you like,
what you didn't like and check out the
how to be playlist down below peace.